ce registre contient les plus anciens
actes de baptême mariage et sépulture
enregistrées dans l'île de 1667 à 1718
jusqu'en 1792 l'écurie était chargé de
constater l'état civil des habitants
les registres paroissiaux furent au
début des registres contenants à la fois
des actes de baptême de mariage et de
sépulture de tous les paroissiens qui
soient blancs noirs ou libres et ce
n'est que vert
1770 qu'une distinction est faite entre
l'état civil des blancs et des libres
d'une part et l'état civil des esclaves
le premier acte de baptême et celui
détienne peau il est enregistré le 7
août
il est le fils de Pierre pot et Dan
Biard
sont parrain et Étienne Regnault
commandant de Lille et sa mère
Antoinette bio
l'acte est signé du père Louis de
l'anonymod de matos premier curé de
Lille
le premier acte de baptême d'un enfant
noir est enregistré le 29 juin 1669
c'est celui de Pierre Diane vinanoro il
est le fils de djembé et de Rennes
siamalaza en 1671 toute la population
est catholique tous les Malgaches
débarqués dans l'île sont baptisés et
intégrés dans la religion catholique
ce registre permet de retrouver la trace
des descendants des premiers ménages
blancs noirs et mixte établi dans l'île
on peut citer les noms de Waro Touchard
fontaine riquebourg
et les Malgaches en case et Marie marron